ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้
วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 10 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
สิงหาคมตีพ.ต.ท.อะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565  a คศอะไรคะปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
อังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 9 ค่ะค่ะเสือ
เดือน
สิงหาคมปีพตตปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะกัดพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่ 11 เดือน
เดือน
สิงหาคม AE พ.ต.ต.
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ
ปีพ
2022 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอน
นี้เวลา 4:00 น
14 กี่นาทีเมื่อปี 40 นาทีค่ะ
4:10 นขาก็ยังเป็นคู่ซอสตื่นแล้วก็ค้าตี
4 เนี่ยว่ายังไม่นอนเนี่ยฮะถ้ายังไม่ได้
นอนไม่เต็มตื่นไม่หลับ
[ปรบมือ]
V คะ
ของครูหญิงเนี่ยภูฟ้าตี 4 ใช่ไหมของผู้
หญิงก็
17:00 นห้ามสิ่ง
ของครูอีก 5 โมงเย็นไงผู้หญิงเนี่ยไม่
สบายกำลังจะกินข้าวแล้ว
[เพลง]
ทรายแต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยยังไม่นอนแล้วคุณฟ้าจะ
ง่วงไหมคะ
ไม่ง่วงเลยค่ะครูอู๋ดีค่ะค่ะไม่ง่วงเนี่ย
คุณครูฟ้าจะได้
ๆเนี่ยอิงฟ้าไงเราก็ฟ้าล่ะผมหน้าไม้ใหญ่
วะมีความ
รู้ป๊าจะได้คิดถ้าไม่ง่วงแล้วลูกค้าจะได้
คิดเก่งๆไงคะ
คิดอะไรคู่หญิงจะให้ครูฟ้าคิดอะไรคะเอ้า
วันนี้ครูหญิงก็มีคำถาม
ถ้าถามว่า
คำถามถามว่าเนี่ยครูฟ้าเนี่ยพูดคำถามนะ
ครูฟ้าขาค่ะ
ผู้หญิงว่าอะไรคะ
โดเรมอน
ปาร์คนักเรียนบอกว่ากูฟ้าเลิกคิด
โดราเอมอนได้แล้ว
ผู้หญิงก็สีฟ้าผู้หญิงวาดหน้ากลม
เก่งว่าอ่างกาแต่วงกลมวงกลมที่ครูหญิงว่า
เนี่ยอะไรคุยจะวาดอะไรวงกลมเนี่ยอะไร
เลยคิดว่า
ครูฝาสีฟ้านะต้องดูด้วยนะวงกลมเนี่ยสีฟ้า
โลกหรอคะ
ไม่ใช่ครูฟ้านะพี่ยังไม่ได้ไหว้ครูป๊ามัน
บอกอะไร
มันแล้วโลกโลก
เก่งว่าค่า
โลกใช่ไหมโลกก็จะมี
มีอะไรคะ
ประเทศไทย
เหมือนหนูจะไทยออสเตรเลีย 4
You  can แคนาดาอเมริกา
นี่ทำไมประเทศไทย
เล่นให้ยุโรปเอเชียที่ประเทศไทยที่ไหนดี
มากนะคะก็ใหญ่จังเลยค่ะหน่อยก็
นี่ก็คือคุณแม่จิบรับฟรีไม่โอเคนะคะนัก
เรียนยุ้ย
ว่าประเทศไทยเนี่ยไอ้สมัยในโลกประเทศไทย
เล็กๆนะคะมันจะมียุโรปอันนี้เป็นเอเชีย
ใช่ไหมรัสเซียแคนาดา
กรีนแลนด์นี่เนาะแอฟริกาขอโทษค่ะแอฟริกา
นี่คือโลกของเราใช่ไหมโลกเนี่ยก็จะมีอัน
นี้เขาอี้บเนาะอันนี้คือทวีปนักเรียนช่วย
ฟังแล้วใช่ไหมโลกแบบมี 7 ทวีปคือ
1 ทวีปไทยค่ะอ๋อถ้าวิ่งอเมริกาใต้
ทวีป
อเมริกาเหนือ
ในทวีปยุโรปเอเชีย
แอฟริกา
ทวีปออสเตรเลียอะไร
แล้วก็ทวีป
อะไรนะฮะฟ้าติดปีกอา
ถูกป่ะ
ทวีอันตอนสิก้าใช่มั้ยอะเราไม่ได้เป็น
ทวีปหมายใช่สิ High ใช่ไหมคะมีทวีปเราก็
ในทวีปในทวีปก็จะมีประเทศประเทศประเทศ
ประเทศในเหมือนประเทศไทยอยู่ทวีปอะไร
ประเทศไทยอยู่ทวีป
ยุโรป
เอเชีย
เก่งมากค่ะใช่ไหมคะนี่คือโลกของเราทำไมอะ
นี้คืนลูกก็จะมีได้น้ำไม่มีอะไรนะทะเลก็
มีอเร
นท์และโล่นะคะคำถามของครูหญิงวันนี้เนี่ย
เกี่ยวกับโลกค่ะครูฟังน้า
อะไรล่ะผู้หญิงหญิงจะถาม
อะไรเกี่ยวกับโลกคะเอาครีมก็จะถาม
ถามครูฟ้าว่าถ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะเปลี่ยน
อะไรก็ได้ในโลกเนี่ยได้ 1 อย่างนะเปลี่ยน
หนึ่งอย่างในโลกครูฟ้าอยากจะเปลี่ยนอะไร
เปลี่ยนอะไรก็ได้ 1 อย่างในโลก
เพลงฟ้าเปลี่ยนอะไรมีอัคแซมโป้ม้าผู้หญิง
เปลี่ยนเมื่อคือเปลี่ยนอะไรอ่ะ
อย่างเช่นได้เปลี่ยนอะไรก็ได้เปลี่ยนให้
โลกนี้แต่ตอนนี้ทุกคนพูดภาษาอังกฤษเป็นคน
ถ้าคนคนไทยอยากคุยกับคนสเปนคนสเปนพูดภาษา
ไทยไม่ได้คนไทยพูดภาษาอังกฤษไม่ได้พูด
ภาษาสเปนไม่ได้คนสเปนคนไทยก็ต้องคุยภาษา
อังกฤษอย่างทุกคนต้องคุยภาษาภาษากลางเป็น
ภาษาอังกฤษใช่ไหมครูหญิงก็บอกว่าโอเค
เปลี่ยนไม่เอา
ไม่เอา
ผู้หญิงจะไม่เอาอะไรไม่เอาคุยคนละภาษาหรอ
ไม่ก็ให้ทุกคนพูดภาษาไทย
เดี๋ยว
ทุกคนในโลกต้องเรียนภาษาไทยเมื่อก่อนนะ
ทุกคนทุกคนทุกคนเนี่ยเรียนภาษาอังกฤษคน
ไทยเรียนภาษาอังกฤษเหตุผลสเปนคนจีนคนแบ็ค
ซิงโกะคนบราซิลคนญี่ปุ่นเรียนภาษาอังกฤษ
เกลียดเรียนภาษาไทยบ้างเอเอ
ช่วงไหนก็เปลี่ยนไงคุยก็เล่นถามกูฟ้าว่า
ถ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยเปลี่ยนหนึ่งอย่างในโลกได้
อยากเปลี่ยนอะไร
ไฟฟ้าอยากให้
ผู้หญิงน่ะไม่มีไหม example นะคะคุยนัก
เรียนคู่ฟ้าเนี่ยถ้ากูฟ้าจะเปลี่ยนช่าง
ร้านก็มีหลายอย่างมันก็แค่ 1 อย่างหนึ่ง
อย่างพอค่ะ
สีฟ้าอยากเปลี่ยนให้
มี
มีอะไรคะอ่า
ตั้งนะไม่อยากเปลี่ยนให้ผู้ชายอ่ะ
ให้กับผู้หญิง
แข็งแรงเหมือนกัน
นี่โลกเราก็เปลี่ยนโลกไงเปลี่ยนให้ผู้
หญิงทุกคนในโลกเธอ
แข็งแรงเหรอผู้ชาย
ผู้หญิงเข้าใจแล้วก็คือผู้ชายอ่าผู้ชายชก
มวยได้ผู้หญิงชกมวยได้อ๋ออ๋อครูฟ้าเนี่ย
อยากเปลี่ยนให้ผู้ชายกับผู้หญิง
เรือนเอาแล้วกันนะคะเข้ากันใช่ฮะแข็งแรง
เท่ากันเพราะว่าตอนนี้เนี่ยผู้ชายจะแข็ง
แรงมากกว่าใช่มั้ยล่ะผู้ชายแข็งแรงมาก
กว่ายกของ f  100 กิโลกรัม
ได้ผู้หญิงล่ะผู้หญิงอ่ะจะไม่ถึง 100
กิโลน่าจะซักประมาณ 5  4 กิโลเมตรนะ
อะไรเงี้ยผู้หญิงก็จะได้แบบผู้หญิงก็จะ
แข็งแรง
น้อยกว่าผู้ชายใช่ไหมปกติมันก็เลยอยากให้
ผู้ชายกับผู้หญิงแข็งแรงเหมือนกันเวลาฟ้า
ดูทีวีเนี่ย
เราก็จะดูโอลิมปิคเอา
ถ้าโอลิมปิคเนี่ยก็ผู้ชายแข่งกับผู้ชาย
ผู้หญิงแต่งกับผู้หญิงกูไม่อยากให้
เปลี่ยนเหรอคะใช่หากว่าอยากให้เปลี่ยนหัก
เพราะว่ากูเบื่อนะคะผู้ชายแข่งกับผู้ชาย
ผู้หญิง
เบื่อก็อยากให้ผู้ชาย
แข่งกับผู้หญิงเออให้แข็งแรงเหมือนกัน
โอลิมปิกก็จะแข็งเท่าดูผู้หญิงเข้าใจแล้ว
ก็คือครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่อยากให้ต้องมี
โทรศัพท์ไม่ต้องมีผู้ชายนะถ้าผู้หญิงไม่
มีไม่มีไม่มีทุกคนเหมือนกันไปผู้ชายคนที่
เป็นผู้ชายเนี่ย
อ่ะใส่กระโปรงธรรมดาได้ไม่ต้องคิดทำไมผู้
ชายใส่กระโปรงอะไรอย่างนี้หรอก็เคยไงก็
ได้
ไม่รู้วันนั้นคุยผู้หญิงถาม
ชายหาด้วยค่ะแล้วก็แข็งแรงด้วยฟ้าอยากให้
แข็งแรงเท่ากันภูเขาก็จะ
muay  Thai  thai  boxing กับผู้ชายก็
ได้อะไรอย่างเงี้ยครูฟ้าคิดอย่าชุดรวยกับ
ผู้ชายใช่ไหมไงอ่ะไม่ต้องมวยไทยกับผู้ชาย
นะฮะก็เลยน่าจะแข็งแรงเท่ากันได้
อันนี้ก็คือถ้าครูครับเปลี่ยนโลกได้หนึ่ง
ข้อนี้ขึ้นฟ้าอยากเปลี่ยนใช่ว่าจะเปลี่ยน
ผู้ชายกับผู้หญิงแข็งแรง
คะแล้วก็เข้ากันทำอะไรเหมือนกันได้แบบนี้
ครับก็ดีน่ะก็ดีว่าจะได้ไม่ต้องกลัวเวลา
ไปข้างนอกล่ะแล้วครูหญิงล่ะคะครูหญิง
คิดอยากจะเปลี่ยนอะไรในโลกของเรา
ผู้หญิงเปลี่ยนได้ 100 ข้อใช่ไหม
ผู้หญิงเอา 1  1 ข้อนะก็
ครูหญิง
ผู้หญิงขอเอารูปโลกกลับมาก่อนนะคะ
ถ้าโลกใช่ไหมอันนี้คือโลกของเรา
ถ้าครูหญิงจะเปลี่ยนโลกได้ 1 อย่างนะครู
หญิงอยากจะเปลี่ยนให้โลกนี้ไม่มีประเทศ
ค่ะอ่าว่าทำไมครูหญิงตอนนี้โลกของเรามี
ประเทศนะคะนักเรียนมีกี่ประเทศพระครูฟ้า
มีมี
แก้ว 400  3 หรือ 2 นะไม่รู้เหมือนกันนะ
ครับไม่เอาผู้หญิง 13 หรือว่า
192 ประเทศใช่ไหมประเทศไทยประเทศจีน
ประเทศอเมริกาประเทศสเปนประเทศอังกฤษ
ประเทศบราซิลประเทศออสเตรเลียประเทศ
สิงคโปร์ประเทศเนี่ยใช่ 100 ปี 1 ใส่ค่ะ
มี 1  2  3  4  5  6  7 มี 7 ทวีปใช่ไหม
ในทวีปก็มีประเทศประเทศประเทศคู่หญิง
เนี่ยคิดเปลี่ยนให้ไม่มี
193 ประเทศทั้งหมดเนี่ยเป็นหนึ่งประเทศ
กับประเทศโลกประเทศ
เออ
กู
ประเทศโลกแต่คนไทย
ก็พูดภาษาตัวเองได้นะสมัยเหมือนประเทศ
อินเดียเงี้ยประเทศอินเดียประเทศจีนพูด
หลายๆภาษาเหมือนกันรัฐเหตุรู้ทุกคนเนี่ย
มี Passport อ่ะพี่ไม่เอา passport มา
พาสปอร์ตใช่ไหมคะหมวยพาสปอร์ตทัดช่อเนี่ย
ก็เป็นโรคสมัยนี้เป็นพาสปอร์ตเมื่อก่อน
Passport ก็จะเป็นไข้ในพาสปอร์ตไทยแลนด์
ไม่เอานะก็เปลี่ยนเป็นพาสปอร์ต
เราก็โลกแล้วก็
เก่ง passport โลกด้วยภูฟ้าอยากไปไหนก็
ได้ไม่ต้องมีวีซ่า
ขอทุกคนมีเครื่องหมายทางหมดในโลกประเทศ
เดียวกันก็
รักกัน
ที่เกี่ยวกับไหมก็รักกันไม่ได้
ไม่ทะเลาะกันคือก็อาจจะทะเลาะกันแต่ว่า
แต่ทำไมทีเดียวกันเนี้ยเขาจะได้มีคนต่างๆ
นิดหน่อยไงก็จะมีทีมใช่ไหมที่ต้องดูแลลูก
ของเรา
ประเทศโลกที่คิดว่า
นี่ B เหมือนกันนะคะว่าจะได้ไปเที่ยวหลาย
ๆประเทศใช่ไหมกูฟ้าไปอยู่ไทยแล้วก็จะไปไป
ไปเห้ยพูดฟ้าถ้ามันเป็นประเทศโลกมันก็ไม่
ต้องมี passport สิใช่มันก็ต้องใช้
พาสปอร์ตมาแล้วไม่ต้องใช้พาสปอร์ตใช่ไหม
คะเราใช้ passport สำหรับไปไปดวงจันทร์
นอกโลกใช่
ไม่รู้อ้างจากไม่ต้องไปค่ะร้อนไม่ถ้าตอน
นี้เนี่ยถ้าสมมติที่ไทยเนี่ยที่ไทยเนี่ย
เดือน
เมษายนโอ 40 องศาร้อนมากๆรู้หาก็ไปแคนาดา
ไปเชียงใหม่ไปภูเก็ต
ประเทศเดียวกัน
ฉันผู้หญิงดีมากเลยห่านี้ไปเกิดที่สายผู้
หญิงก็เลยคิดว่าถ้าเปลี่ยนได้ 1 อย่างก็
อยากให้ไม่มีประเทศนะคะทางบทเป็นประเทศ
เดียวกันหมาถ้าทั้งหมดเนี่ยเป็นประเทศ
เดียวกันแล้วพูดได้หนึ่งภาษาเท่านั้นครู
ฟ้าคิดว่าอยากให้พูดอาสาอะไรดีอ่ะเลือกมา
1 ภาษาภาษาอะไรก็ได้นะภาษาไทยอ่ะ
นักเรียนก็ไม่ใช่เพราะว่ากูฟ้าเป็นคนไทย
นะคะแต่จริงๆก็เป็นคนไทยนั่นแหละว่าก็เลย
ก็พอแล้วกูมาเป็นคนไทยก็ให้เรื่องภาษาไทย
หรอไม่กูไปคิดว่าภาษาไทยมันสนุกนะเนี่ย
มาสนุกยินบ้างคือคนไทยอ่ะกูฟ้าเป็นคนที่
เล่นโซเชียลไงเราเวลาเราไม่อยากให้ประเทศ
อื่นรู้ว่าเราคุยอะไรกันน่ะมันจะมีช่วง
ใช่ว่าคนไทยคุยกันใช่ไหมกูในทวิตเตอร์นะ
คะไม่มีคนไทยใช้ทวิตเตอร์น้องคุยกันคุย
กัน
คือประเทศอื่นอยากรู้ว่าคนไทยคุยอะไรกัน
คนอเมริกาคนออสเตรเลียคนจีนเกาหลีญี่ปุ่น
อะไรเงี้ยก็ใช้ Google  Translate ไงแต่ง
คือเจอแต่คนไทยเดี๋ยวมันมีการพิมพ์ที่
Google  Translate ก็ไม่เข้าใจไม่เข้าใจ
ไม่เข้าใจวิธีอยู่คือคนไทยเท่านั้นที่ใจ
ก็เลยคิดว่าศุกร์
ผมคิดว่าถ้ามีประเทศเดียวก็ประเทศโลกแล้ว
ก็พูดภาษาเดียวก็คือให้พูดภาษาไทยใช่ไหม
กูฟังว่าภาษาไทยเป็นภาษาที่
เราอยากพูดอะไรก็ได้อ่ะมันสนุกอ้ะมันเยอะ
นักเรียนเยอะมากอยากพูดอะไรก็พูดอย่าง
เงี้ยเออมันเยอะก็เลยมันเป็นภาษาที่สนุก
ดีค่ะเป็นคนไทยรู้สึกว่าบางคำก็ต้องพูด
ภาษาไทยนั่นแหละถึงเดินมีฟิลลิ่งไง
ก็หญิงล่ะหมดเวลาหรือยังอย่างค่ะครูหญิง
หรอ
ครูหญิงคิดว่าแม่ภาษาไทยแล้วกันในภูเขา
พูดไปแล้วผู้หญิงอยากให้พูดภาษาสเปนค่ะ
ครูป่าทำไมถึงเป็นสระภาษาสภา
ทำไมถึงเป็นภาษาสเปนผู้หญิงก็คิดว่าวัน
เวลาที่ก้นใช่ไหมคนคนนะผู้ชายเนี่ยคุยกัน
อันนี้ก็นี้ก็ผู้หญิงแล้วก็คุยกันนะคะ
ภาษาสเปนเนี่ยวิ่งคิดว่าภาษาสเปนก็เวลา
ฟังแล้วมันรู้สึกสนุกดีเหมือนคล้ายๆภาษา
ไทยอ่ะเหนียวไม่เข้าใจภาษาสเปนนะแต่เวลา
ฟังภาษาสเปนแล้วรู้สึกมันสนุกแบบไม่เป็น
ภาษาที่ดูแบบดูคนแบบเส้นตลอดเวลาไรอย่าง
เนี้ยก็เลยรู้สึกว่าแบบรอเรือเยอะๆเหมือน
ภาษาไทยด้วยมากกว่าภาษาไทยก็เลยคิดว่า
ภาษาสเปนก็สนุกดีนะนุ้ยนั่นแหละสนใจตัว
เองให้นี้แล้วนักเรียนล่ะถ้านักเรียน
เนี่ยเปลี่ยนโลกได้ 1 อย่างนักเรียนอาจจะ
เปลี่ยนอะไรนะคะก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้เนาะ
ไงหาซึ่งวันนี้เงียบไปก่อนได้ค่ะเจอกัน
ใหม่วิดีโอหน้าก็สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ